now if you've already been hit with the
flu should you bother getting the flu
shot a Henderson pediatrician explains
why the answer is yes she also tackles
the ongoing pressure our hospitals are
facing treating those with RSV
people who are getting their flu shots
are down dramatically down and and
that's that's frightening Dr Kerry wijay
singha of Siena Pediatrics believes
we're going to see a very active flu
season she encourages everyone to get a
flu shot even kids and adults who have
already been hit with the flu this
season I have seen in very bad flu
Seasons where I'll have a child say now
have influenza A and months expire even
and they don't get the flu vaccine and
they get influenza B so they've had flu
twice in like one winter a rough winter
with a trio of viral threats including
flu RSV and covet almost a third of the
kids Dr wijay singhas seeing have the
respiratory infection RSV it's hitting
babies all the way up to teenagers it's
very contagious impacting lungs and
breathing ability we're naturally
concerned about what everybody's
reporting the RSV and children below two
years of age
um you know some of the babies are going
to the hospital in respiratory distress
around sunrise rise State Road Siena I'm
sure Summerlin that they are kind of
getting to Max Capacity too RSV is
seasonal it showed up in southern Nevada
earlier this year due to people
traveling and no mask mandates if one of
your kids has RSV you need to constantly
be cleaning as it can live on surfaces
for up to 24 hours and here's something
else to consider if you have a good
family member that can take care of the
child with RSV and just try to separate
them for at least a good week I know it
sounds very harsh but that's that's a
better way to save a baby from getting
RSV and then going to the hospital
separating the siblings for that week
period She says and a possible way to
protect a mother and young infant from
RSV infection is a vaccine given to
women during pregnancy which would pass
protection to their unborn child this
may help to prevent RSV and the child's
first few months of life when they of
course are the most vulnerable to
infection